good morning believe nation today's
message is at least try opening you
David show for me the saddest thing when
I see young people that have already
like given in yeah I'm like that's the
time you fight that's the time that you
should try and fail and try again and
then it's like when you get old you're
like at least I tried didn't work out
you know so I said look man I'm gonna go
for it and if I end up broke or poor or
whatever then getting you know at least
I tried you know I love this message
because everybody has goals everybody
has dreams everybody has a future life
an ideal life that they want to set up
for themselves and the difference
between the people who won't actually
realized our dream life the people who
actually hit their goals are the people
who actually try to do things instead of
just daydreaming about it I've never
been one to have huge bucket lists worth
of ideas I don't have these things that
I wish I could do as soon as there's
something that enters into my head of I
wish I could go do that I end up finding
a way to go out and do it I take action
immediately so the example I got in my
head that I wanted to build a house I
want to build the dream house from
scratch and it just started off as some
goal as some one day I'm gonna go out
and do this and from the moment that
that thought entered my head within a
year later I had purchased a property
and began demolition and began building
a 5,000 square-foot house for myself and
that's not to brag and that's not to say
how special I am it's just to show that
if you want something in your life if
you want a big change to happen then you
have to at least try and not be the guy
or the girl who 20 years later looks
back on their life as a man I wish I
gave it my shot when I had that
opportunity if a thought enters your
mind for a better life for yourself a
dream goal that you want to go and chase
you have to at least try
so my question of the day for you guys
today is what's something that you've
had in your head for a long time
you wish you could start at that you
wish you would get going you wish you
would try what is that thing that you
just haven't done yet leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of interesa